especially to have every Weinstein get
the first song today
hi guys good morning so this is a joint
work with Sasha golovanov and ZEB vir
I know Sasha I gave this talk in the
previous workshop so I apologized a few
of you you need to hear some of it again
it was a shorter version of the talk on
the upside we have a kind of a
significant new result which was proven
only the kind of last two weeks which is
why the paper is not out so hopefully it
will contain some new things towards
them all right so this talk is gonna be
about mostly about data structures so
data structure data structure is
basically just a compact way to present
or encode information in a database so
that queries about the underlying data
can be answering the static data
structure model we are given a database
of n elements and this could be
essentially anything you can think of a
and vertex graph and bit string set of
end points in some high dimensional
space and you need to pre process this
data that I give you an event into kind
of cheap memory as memory so such that
each query from a predefined set of Q
queries let's say n cubed query needs to
be answered by few memory accesses kind
of bite with few ayahs what important
example is the orthogonal range counting
problem where the database is just a
collection of endpoints in the N squared
planar grid so there are n squared
points on this grid and the query is
just a point on the grid which defines
an axis parallel rectangle the goal is
to report the number of points in this
correctly
let me save you the marketing pitch for
why this problem is important this is
kind of a very so Amazon needs to solve
this problem basis and this is a really
fundamental problem so any such problem
admits kind of to extreme naive
solutions one of them is kind of to
cheat and store all the answers so the
query time of course will be optimal
right you just read off the answer but
the space unfortunately is kind of big
you need to store all the queries and
this N squared can be easily like n to
the tenth so typically we have a
polynomial number solution is to do the
opposite so no clever pre-processing so
you just store the database in the wrong
no clever encoding no nothing and of
course the space is optimal right any
non degenerate data structure problem
you have to store at least the number
the input data otherwise all bets are
off right unfortunately though the query
time because you didn't do anything
clever in pre-processing time you will
just have to there's nothing better you
can do than just a linear scan so the
query time will be linear that makes
sense
and of course the the National question
is there anything in between right so
can we do anything more clever that
trades off the time and space and static
data structure lower bounds aim to
quantify this trade-off by proving
unconditional lower bounds on the
trade-off between time and space right
okay so I want to prove lower bounds we
need a model for data structures and the
most compelling model for proving data
structure lower bounds is the so called
cell probe model which is a you know
it's a very kind of crude abstraction of
what a data structure actually is it
basically views a data structure is just
a table of cells plus a decision tree or
a query algorithm more formally an st
data structure the cell phone model is
just a pair of kind of two objects one
of them is a pre-processing function it
takes your input database of size of it
you process it into s memory cells this
pre-processing function is completely
arbitrary so you know you can literally
encode anything you want
no computational constraints no nothing
anything you want using s bits of s
memory cells each cell typically
contains log and bits of information and
the reason why the word size is usually
log n is because you want to at least be
able to index an element your database
and you want to at least store a pointer
to some other memory cells so it's
usually log of n which is roughly log of
the query the number of queries because
the queries are to the polynomial and
and that's it set up the second objects
is just okay once you have this memory
state of the data structure the query
algorithm specifies for each query a set
of its most t memory cells that reading
those cells will retrieve the correct
answer
for the jQuery so far so good
sorry so in general the query algorithm
is a depth T decision tree in the
adaptive model but if the data structure
is non adaptive which believe which will
be the focus of this talk then it's
literally a depth two circuit with with
s so the middle layers of with S which
is larger and top fanning though is very
small as any poly logarithmic or
something so it's kind of a very
specific model of circuit the main point
is that the bottom gates are unbounded
fanon and completely arbitrary kind of
both to the top of the bunch
questions so far all right so that's a
cell probe st data structure and you
know this model is kind of extremely
powerful in the sense that it renders
time-space trade-offs completely in an
information theoretic question there is
no it's it's a non uniform model so
there's no absolutely no computational
constraints in kind of the claim to fame
of this model is that literally captures
any data structure lower bound you can
imagine regardless if it's you know
whether it's implemented on with a C++
or Java code or on some Intel compiler
and so forth since the gates are
arbitrary this small is non-uniform it
literally doesn't care about any
computational constraint so any so all
all computations on probe cells are
completely free of charges all I care
about is how many cells you store and
how many ions you have all right
or unfortunately not surprisingly this
abstraction also makes it very difficult
to prove unconditional lower bounds and
more specifically even though most data
structure phones are a random data
structure problem with polynomially many
queries there's kind of nothing better
than you can do then either storing all
the query all the answers or you know
probing all the cells which is so kind
of for a typical data structure problem
there's nothing better that you can do
than just the naive extreme solutions
just kind of very actually the bound is
much stronger you need like m to the one
- little o of one so it's really nothing
better you can do in contrast we know
that for any data structure problem we
do have these you know incredible data
structures and in particular the highest
explicit lower bound we have for any
data structure problem with polynomial
many queries is following bound it's log
the number of queries which is M is like
enter the tenth so it's like log n right
over log space over and particularly if
you want to prove lower rounds against
linear space data structures which use
you know 10 and bit in 10 n space you
get a logarithmic lower bound and this
is kind of the record so far it was I
mean okay the good news is it was a
proven for kind of not just contrived
problems but for like problems we
actually care about some custom
improvement for evaluation problem for
range counting problem pass to your
neighbor search maybe up to a log log
and loss in the query but so we have
this lower bound for kind of problems we
care about
but unfortunately there's no higher
SubPop lower bounds even for
non-adaptive data structures so we don't
know how to separate ad apptivity from
nonnative to be sort of non-adaptive
data structures in the static model this
is kind of in sharp contrast to the
dynamic models so the role that
adaptivity plays in the dynamic model is
crucial kind of and maybe not very
surprising because the data is online in
the static model beating this lower
bound asymptotically it would be kind of
a real breakthrough even for non
adaptive questions
alright so given the you know the
difficulty of proving separable or about
a natural and kind of intermediate
milestone similar to the circuit
complexity and lower bound Enterprise is
to consider a restricted model of data
structures and indeed over the years
several restricted models data
structures were considered such as the
the pointer machine is the word round
model in some of the brake models most
notably the linear group model so since
linear aquarias are kind of very
ubiquitous and important this long
received quite a bit of attention so a
linear data structure problem is nothing
else but just a matrix in M by n matrix
and the input database is just over some
you know your favorite finite field at
the input database is just of n bit and
letter string so in n dimensional vector
X the queries are specified are just the
rows of this matrix right so we have M
maybe n to the 10 queries and the answer
to the J query is what you would guess
is just the dot product between the J
throw and the eye
all right so does it make sense so this
is a data structure problem an SD linear
data structure is what you would think
is just restricting the gates of this
circuit to being linear similar to
cancer and so a linear data structure
can store s elements of the field F
basically s linear functions but we will
see this is kind of without loss of
generality the important thing is that
the query right so the top layer of this
circuit needs to answer each query with
a t sparse linear combination of those
memory cells so it's a nice exercise to
show that if the top layer is linear you
can for free linearize the the bottom
layer so this is actually not a real
nice and yeah so linear queries are kind
of an important special case so the
range counting problem we saw in the
beginning of the talk is a linear
problem one way to see it is that you
know the the database the the endpoints
are just the indicator vector of
dimension N squared and they indicate
one wherever you have a point the rows
the queries are just the indicator
vectors of the rectangles of all
possible record right and then you just
compute the dot product counts it counts
the points inside if you can of course
imagine non orthogonal range counting
problems where you need you have balls
or triangles instead and these are
conjectured to be hard so linear data
structure problems are both interesting
and kind of known trivial to solve so
the partial sum problems just an example
another example is just the lower
triangular matrix polynomial evaluation
is just a vandermonde matrix
what else dictionaries are just identity
matrix so we have and you know that the
saga go out and goes on so kind of we
have no higher lower bounds and then
this log M over log space over and even
for non adaptive linear data structures
so somehow even in the group model we do
with how we don't know how to beat this
this down and once again this is in
sharp contrast to the dynamic online
model there so Casper has a nice paper
where we can prove actually polynomial
definitely poly logarithmic but even
polynomial lower bounds on the query or
update time so this shows this like a
real big difference between this kind of
a static and dynamic model this is in
particularly there's no super
logarithmic lower bound even against
linear space so kind of this is kind of
the most the first thing we would try to
program your streak the data structure
to store a hundred and
I okay before we present the the result
kind of at a very high level one of the
many main messages of this talk this is
kind of not really a coincidence that
it's not a coincidence we're stuck here
in some sense a logarithmic improvement
or in other regimes even any asymptotic
improvement even against arbitrarily
small linear space so even if you
restrict the data structure to store you
know one point zero zero zero zero zero
one memory so it seems like an easy case
for lower bound even then this would
imply kind of breakthrough results in
this yeah well depending on how much you
care about different enterprise we can
debate yeah so I should say before I
kind of getting ahead of myself I should
say in advance that this this will not
be you know a complete like a complete
no-go theorem for data structure lower
bounds in the sense that proving poly
logarithmic let's say log to the ten
query lower bound against linear space
will still not nearly get us to circuit
lower bounds which is kind of log
circuits will we'll get to that so so
kind of don't despair already we will
see that only if you prove kind of we'll
see this in the end so only if we prove
extremely strong data structure lower
bound only then will it actually imply
circuit lower bound so so there is kind
of some hope I think the main message is
basically a new connection between two
e-publication or models that's that's
the main message and maybe somewhat of a
sign that yeah dynamic lower bounds are
easier to handle the imply static right
for many settings if you prove like more
than Oxford and for dynamic yourself
static upper bounds imagine
they depending there are many problems
yeah for like four inch counting you get
four composable problems like range
counter yeah yeah we can if you prove it
with a certain chronograph technique but
yeah so we can discuss this alright so
one observation could set up the stage
for a result is that an ST linear data
structure for a linear problem M there's
nothing but just a factorization of the
input of the data structure problem into
a product of a sparse matrix right T row
sparse matrix which has T non zeros in
each row times a small matrix so this
matrix can be completely arbitrary but
it's narrow so it has only s and if you
don't see this immediately there may be
one one way to see it is that you know a
linear data structure only needs to be
correct on the on the basis on any basis
right so you can think of the eighth
column of this in our matrix is just
encoding the memory contents of the
million middle layer if the input
database was the ice basis vector right
so we have all the memory contents of
the basis vectors and now to answer the
jet query the J throw the data structure
specifies T nonzero entries that it
wants to read from each right does that
make sense so I think imagine earlier
that the reconstruction is linear
without loss of generality right no the
other way around
it's the reconstruction algorithm is
linear then the middle layer what you
the pre compute the the pre-processing
function is either
I like it's it's a nice exercise
actually so we assumed both are linear
but actually only you only need to
assume that this does that factorization
makes sense questions right so the space
of the data structure is just the number
of columns or the the number of rows of
this region so each row the original
query needs to be expressed as a sum of
tiros these are all equivalent alright
so what does it mean to prove a linear
data structure lower bound just
exhibiting finding a matrix which cannot
be factorized as a sparse times small
matrix
right so linear data structure lower
bounds correspond to finding matrices
which do not admit such factorization
into a product of two matrices one of
which is sparse
in contrast the problem of matrix
rigidity is the problem of finding a
matrix which cannot be factorized into
the some rather than product of a t
sparse plus a low rank matrix so having
formerly a matrix and M by n matrix is
rigid if it is T far in Hamming distance
from any low dimensional subspace or
from any low rank matrix may be one
useful more geometric way to visualize
this is that a matrix M is RT rigid if
for any low dimensional for any R
dimensional subspace L there exists one
row one of the points one of the rows
and M is T far away from the subspace in
Hamming distance make sense this is L is
just a column space of this low rank
matrix
and I do want to stress that okay so
what does it mean for a matrix to be are
too rigid yet another way to view it is
that you need to change you need to
modify key entries in some row of the
matrix in order to decrease the rank
from what it originally was which was
alright and I want to stress that this
is kind of a worst-case notion of
rigidity the somewhat more standard
notion of rigidity is actually 10% of
the rows are actually far from any low
dimensional subspace so global rigidity
or average-case rigidity is what it
seems like a much more powerful notion
and towards the end of the talk we'll
see that actually this is one of our
main new results is that they're
actually equivalent up to a logarithmic
loss in sparsity so I'll get to this
later but I want to stress this notion
of row rigidity or worst case Reggie D
is gonna be important to the results
we'll state but will cause us some
problems later that we will and finally
I want to define this notion which will
not play a major role in this talk but
so just for a kind of purpose of a nice
characterization a matrix is strongly
rigid if it's rigid in any basis so no
matter which basis you choose for the
matrix M it's still hard to reduce the
room this notion kind of only makes
sense for rectangular matrices right for
square matrices you always have the
standard basis right so there's no hope
to prove that but if you if this
confuses you just forget about strong
rigidity just it will not really be used
sorry what you mean by the matrix in any
way
so this property of this equal positions
in principle it's the property of the
which basis you choose for for M right
which basis you choose for your original
matrix and I a strong rigidity means
that okay so think of a n squared by n
matrix it's just you can view it as a a
low dimensional subspace in F to the M
maybe it will be clear later and I
choose any basis you want for this low
dimensional sub saying maybe it will be
clear in a few slides so maybe we can so
playing M by unitary yes yeah exactly so
I am saying that yeah so for square
matrices it doesn't make sense because
you can always transform it into the
standard base writes an N dimensional
subspace in F to the end so it doesn't
make sense so this is the type of
discussion exactly I didn't want to take
into because it confuses you and it's
not going to be important but we can we
can talk about it it will be clear in
very soon you can forget about strong
rigidity for now I think it would just
confuse you for the experts just so just
a two minute motivation for why we care
about rigid eating what are kind of the
Holy Grail parameters so so by the
rigidity we always have two priorities
there's a rank parameter in the sparsity
parameter so so this is gonna be quick
if you don't you know if you're not
familiar with this motivation then it's
fine so now it can be necessary to
understand the talk maybe only the the
last few slides so the main motivation
for studying rigidity is proving
superlinear Lord mountain logarithmic
depth circuits and it falls from from
like a really nice reduction proposed by
valiant in 1977 so kind of all of our
string kinase techniques completely fail
for a logarithmic depth circuits we
don't
how to handle log depth circuits in any
way except this one very nice program
developed by Janet valiant so but
valiant showed is that if you have a
logarithmic depth linear size circuit so
in particular it computes you know at
most 10 n input outputs then if your
function is computed by this logarithmic
def linear size circuit then you can
translate this circuit this circuit it
is all also computed by this depth 2
circuit which is of some very different
kind than the data structure so it's a
depth to circuits where the middle layer
stores actually not larger than and but
fewer than it's like and over a thousand
bits of information and each query so it
the middle layer stores so it computes
the same function that the original
circuit computes the middle func the
middle layer now stores n over a
thousand bits so it cannot possibly
store you cannot recover the answers to
all the quest for this middle there
right because it stores less than the
input less than n so that out so the
queries must be connected also to some
of the inputs right so the picture is
like this each query needs to be
answered as a function this answer
there's a function of two objects one is
those and over a thousand common bits
which are completely arbitrary functions
of the inputs and can be viewed by any
one of the queries plus a very small set
of n you know and to the point one
inputs which are hardwired to the query
and what valiant Jones is really nice
observations that if this circuit
further computes a linear function a
linear transformation similar to data
structure story so these are just
answers to each row M then this
linearity actually induces a
decomposition of the matrix M into the
some sparse plus low rank matrix I'm not
going to explain this but you can see is
the low the sparse the sparse factor B
comes from the fact that each query
reads only and to the point one input
elements and the low rank part comes
from the middle layer right it's low
rank just because it has dimension and
over a thousand this is all I'm gonna
say
so the point if if this didn't then
follow them the main point is that you
know if if a linear circuit computes
your linear transformation M with linear
size and logarithmic debt then this
reduction which is completely
combinatorial but no if you apply it on
linear functions then you get the
composition of M into a sparse plus no
right matrix and the Kuril corollary is
that if we can find an explicit matrix
such that to reduce its rank from n to n
over a thousand requires modifying n to
the point 1 entries in some row of the
matrix and the corollary the
contrapositive is that it cannot be
computed by linear size log that circle
if you don't if you didn't follow this
then you just you can stick around this
motivation the main point is that kind
the Holy Grail parameters we care about
is linear rank or maybe even n over log
log n but let's say n over a thousand
and polynomial sparsity parameter so try
to keep this in mind this kind of very
strong parameters and then the matrix
needs to be nearly squared so
all right so what do we know how about
rigidity lower balance not surprisingly
a random matrix is extremely rigid so
you need even to decrease the rank below
and over to you need to modify like n
over log n entries in the matrix so in
each row so once we go to explicit
constructions once again the situation
is kind of very gloomy so the best lower
bound we have if you want to decrease
the rank to R for any parameter rate
parameter R you need to change roughly n
over R times log n over R entries which
is a mere constant like 10 for square
matrices if we want to decrease the rank
below and yeah so since we were so bad
at proving square matrix rigidity one
nights program proposed by alone panagra
he Anthony Hannon about 10 years ago is
that ok fine if we're so bad at proving
square GDD let's try to prove rigidity
lower bounds on rectangular matrices
which is kind of matrices with you know
again n to the ten rows and and
intuitively this should help remember a
matrix is rigid if for if one row is far
from any low dimensional subspace so if
I give you a list of n to the ten rows
this should only help right link I mean
I'm giving you a budget of more more
potential vectors and you need to fight
against all low dimensional subspaces so
this makes a kind of sense and indeed
they show that you can get some slightly
better a result so we can get rigidity
of log M over N for a matrix with
polynomial in many rows more
specifically for any parameter D they
give a an explicit construct a very
simple error correcting code
construction that has n times 2 to the D
rows so you need to set D to be
logarithmic for this to be polynomial
and in order to decrease the rank below
on over to you need to change these D
entries in each row all right so this is
restated in this
and for poll but for polynomial and this
will never give you better than log log
and right
so this recurring barrier frontier of
log log n is and the main theme remember
this is like extremely far even forget
the square versus rectangle this is a
kind of is extremely far from the
Valiants program right valiant wants and
to the point one deep you know the
number of entries you need to modify it
to be like n point one to the point one
so it's just like still extremely far
but this is the current frontier to kind
of be and yeah so it's the better of the
summary so far of the talk so everything
we discuss is that rigidity lower bounds
amount to finding explicit matrix
rectangular matrix possibly that cannot
be factorized as the sum of a sparse
post-iraq matrix whereas data structure
lower bounds in the group model amount
to finding matrices which cannot be
decomposed as a product of a sparse plus
small times yeah so kind of maybe
syntactically you see some differences
of course semantically these
factorizations are very very different
right so it it's not clear how to relate
these these two things and maybe
probably the the key kind of the key of
division where the the the key point of
view for relating these two
factorizations is to look not on the row
space of the major not in the the rows
but actually is the on the column space
of this matrix in more formally we want
to view m not as a set of n to the ten
rows in X to the n but as a set of as a
low dimensional n-dimensional subspace
of F to the M so it's a very small n
dimensional subspace inside F n to the
ten right
but did that makes us so let's look at
mmm is a and cat om is as a girl m-by-n
matrix we can view we can look at its
column space so it's just an
n-dimensional subspace in if to the M
because we assume the matrix is can for
right and we say kind of the key
definition here in this socket is the
following we say that a subspace in F to
the M is T sparse
if it is the column space of a T spot of
the T Rho sparse matrix so it's a little
weird but it will be important for us so
there's this parse so so this is a
property of subspaces but there's an
existential quantifier on the basis no
yes right right now we will okay so this
is a property of of subspaces which has
nothing to do with with the basis so far
is if there exists a basis which is yeah
exactly
exactly so if so another way of saying
it is what module said a subspace is T
sparse if there exists a sparse matrix
my matrix a which has at most T non
zeros in each row that generates that
the column space of this matrix
generates this alright now we make the
two key definitions of the stock the
inner dimension of the matrix M is the
largest dimensional intersection that
your original matrix M can have with any
T sparse and dimensional subspace so
here's the game I give you look at the
end look at the column space of M in
general this is an n-dimensional
subspace in F to them right but it's
very non sparse so think of the
vandermonde matrix certainly not it's
not generated by sparse matrix and the
game is the for I give you a budget of n
dimensions but you have to generate it
with a sparse matrix and your goal is to
cover as much as you can to intersect
the original subspace as much as you can
and the inner dimension with perhaps
Parsi priority is just the largest
dimension of such intersection questions
the outer dimension of the matrix
denoted by capital D is the minimum
dimension of a T sparse subspace that
doesn't only intersect but it actually
covers the entire matrix so now the game
is different now I I force you to
actually contain the entire space which
is not sparse so you have to pay some
more dimensions right but now I force
you to actually contain the column space
of of your non sparse
so in the next five minutes I want to
convince you that this is kind of the
key fact that makes the rest of the
results or at least most of them kind of
fairly simple and I convinced you that
the property of being rigid or strongly
rigid actually is exactly the property
of having low inner dimension and the
property of a matrix of okay so a matrix
is rigid if and only if it has low inner
dimension in a matrix does not admit the
matrix does not admit an efficient data
structure so it has a data structure
lower bound if and only if it has large
outer dimension so that's the goal in
the next five exactly so the whole
connection will come throughout relating
these to it so the first one which is a
simple lemma but it's somehow the key to
taste most of the result is the
following so I claim that a matrix is
not in this is is not rigid if it is
sparse on some large dimensional
subspace of its column space all right
so we're going to prove that a matrix is
not epsilon and T rigid so you can
decrease the rank below Epsilon and by
modifying only key entries in each
matrix this means that the matrix has to
be T sparse on some large n dimension on
some N dimensional subspace which
exactly means that the inner dimension
is large right to being that I think
that was exactly the that exactly
corresponds to the inner dimension being
large like
blammo makes them all right so all right
so suppose your matrix is not rigid so
by definition it admits a decomposition
into a sparse plus low rank matrix and
note that because rank is sub additive
then the rank of a right must be very
high because M is without was full rank
it has rank N and I B has low rank so a
has to have rank at least so now let the
let t be the the linear map the linear
transformation whose kernel is are
precisely the columns of M we can always
construct such linear transformation
right I just put all the the n columns
of M in the kernel and just extend it to
now take this linear transformation T
and apply it on both sides of this
equality so what will happen to the left
side l0 out right because the kernel
that is precisely the column space of M
so we get that you know by switching
side that heat minus da equals 2 oh
sorry
should be should have been at T naught
so do you agree that the rank of in
particular the rank of T a is equal to
the rank of T B questions about this
right let's think about so and we know
that the rank of T B cannot be more than
epsilon and right because rank is sub
multiplicative you cannot increase the
rank by multiplying by a matrix and the
rank of B was very small absolutely so
how could it be that the rank of T a is
small a had very large rank to begin
with the only way it can decrease to
below epsilon n is if it had a very
large intersection with the kernel of T
right if it has less than 1 minus 2
epsilon and intersection then the rank
will remain larger than epsilon and that
contradiction that's here
right so it's a simple claim where was
this person you know where do you get
this person so the point was that the
column space of a by definition of our
sparse so we we kind of use it's kind of
a black box but it was it was crucially
used alright so and actually you can
prove the other way around so this only
used rigidity standard VG for the other
way around if you think about it you
cannot prove it it's a it's a if you
want to prove this for the other
direction you have to use strong rigid e
because it's not a property of the base
it has to be for any basis right because
it's a property of subspaces but we're
not getting you we're only gonna use
this lemma so let's call this lemma
lemma star and this is the only
direction we'll use I should say that
patter in push-up already essentially
they define a subtly different notion of
inner and outer dimension and they
proved non-trivial direction in somewhat
different arguments so it was hidden in
some Russian Journal paper they wrote so
it's it's actually slightly different
but they already essentially observed
that all right
okay so hopefully you convince ourselves
that matrix is rigid every if and only
if its inner dimension is small now I
want to convince you that a matrix does
not admit or okay a matrix admits an
efficient data structure an ST data
struggle linear data structure if and
only if its outer dimension is is small
so in other words we have a lower bound
if the outer dimension is large
it was just a one-way right for strong
virginity you can prove the other way
around it's actually easier
it's the trivial condom but we won't use
it so I just it's just for the
characterization really okay so we'll
have to call them a little faster for me
okay so and so this this this is nothing
more than just an observation I claim
that right so if a data if problem we've
made a linear problem it's a linear SD
data structure it admits this
factorization which means that so this
factorization is exactly the the low
dimensional subspace that cover contains
the the matrix a you can see this just
what does that factorization mean means
that every column of M is generated by
the column space of a and B is just a
linear combination encoding this this
this is this factorization right right
so I claim that the column space of a
must contain M and B is the evidence for
that right
we just specifies B there's no sparsity
constraint we just specifies the the
column the linear combination of the
columns that gives you the produced the
column space around so I'm not saying
anything very interesting so okay so
took a nap this is the kind of time to
wake up so everything we discussed boils
down to that kind of statement so the
matrix is admits in Lin and st linear
data structure if and only if it's has
its outer dimension is that most s it's
strongly rigid if and only if its inner
dimension is small so in that
terminology what does it mean to show
that a linear data structure lower bound
implies a rigid matrix it's essentially
equivalent as Madhu proposed to showing
to understand the relationship between
inner dimension and outer image in
particular it means if we can show that
small a large outer dimension
which is a data structure lower bound
implies small inner dimension then we
get this implication that showing that
data structure lower bounds imply
rigidity is equivalent essentially to
showing that large outer dimension
implies small inner dimension just by
this characterization okay so that's
true only for very weak data structure
lower bounds against linear space but I
agree that's a simple implication which
it probably won't have time to discuss
so yeah so the other way around this is
also true but only kind of for kind of
weak data structure or if you can prove
rigidity anytime a ridah you only get a
lower but data structure a little brown
against and 1.01 let me try to discuss
this and like I mean the the main kind
of framework for resolve so this is
essentially exactly what we show right
so we show that if you start if you give
me a matrix whose outer dimension is
large so you it's more than one point
zero one and then we can actually find a
sub matrix right and this so a sub
matrix whose outer dimension with a loss
in sparsity of log n is small is less
than 1 minus epsilon which exactly means
by this characterization that this new
matrix m prime is epsilon and t over log
in region right so if you can ignore the
parameters but morally speaking this is
what what's going on in moreover this
this matrix so we cannot make the proof
exactly explicit this matrix can be
found in using an NP Oracle but this is
still like far beyond like any kind of
circuit lower bounds we know so we so as
far as circuit lower bounds you know P
to the NP constructions are considered
pretty much explicit so we don't know
how to prove certain people
even against you know much much higher
and the corollary is that super
logarithmic you know any super
logarithmic lower bound on data
structures linear data structures would
give you something non-trivial about
rigidity in particular if you prove a
poly log and query time lower bound on
any linear data structure problem even
against even against you know a 1 plus
epsilon one point zero one space which
seems like not a too much to ask then
you would improve this APY construction
by the st. Pauli log factor minus one so
in particular if you give me a super log
squared data structure lower bound in
the group model you would improve the
APY construction right but only for
rectangular matrices and hopefully I'll
have time to show of the implications on
square matrices alright so so this is
does everyone kind of agree with this
corollary right you lose one log factor
because of this and I want to say that
this kind of indicates a threshold
result in data structure lower bounds
because for succinct data structures if
I constrain the data structures to use
not end to end you know one point zero
one n but actually n plus little oven
and plus root n the space then we
actually know polynomial cell probe
lower bounds then we kind of have almost
everything we want and this shows that
once you go to linear space arbitrarily
small
all of a sudden lower bounds become like
extremely like powerful it exists in M
prime yeah say so let's just very
quickly sketch the the theorem the the
proof so the proof says the following
give me your any give me your matrix for
which you have proved the data structure
world on so you prove that the outer
dimension is large is at least but not
terribly large you only need to
since me it's larger than 1.01 and I
will show you I'll give you a P to the N
piece or polynomial number of calls to
an NP Oracle that will produce your sub
matrix of this matrix which is which is
log n which is a rigid with those
parameters alright and now you can you
know the algorithm is not it's not very
difficult it's kind of a simple
recursion watch once you have this these
definitions in hand so let me give a
very quick sketch because they want to
get to the second result so you start
with your matrix right n by n if it's
rigid already which you can check with
an NP Oracle or cowan P Oracle then
you're done right
that's it's not rigid what does it mean
if it's inner dimension is small then by
definition lemma star implies that there
is some large sparse T sparse subspace
that intersects a large fraction 1 minus
2 epsilon of its column space right this
is exactly what this is exactly the
implication of a non rigid matrix it has
a it's sparse on a very large subspace
of its column space alright great so we
so kind of the ideas you know work in
the contrapositive fashion suppose it's
not rigid
I will gradually construct a
too-good-to-be-true cover of the entire
column space and that will contradict
the fact the outer dimension is small I
will cover it with two few dimensions or
space ok good so we're done with like
half of the combs so and and the nice
thing is that alright so this is exactly
what it means that a covers this
fraction of the column space and the
good news is that remember the lemma
says that we managed to cover this
fraction using very cheap we paid for it
only and dimensions right we have a
budget of one point zero one and
dimension so it is so we paid for it
only we have you know 1 plus epsilon n
dimensions to afford and we only paid
and dimensions out of it and we already
covered like 70% of the colonies that's
kind of great great news and now
what we can do is we can just extend
this matrix that we found just greedily
right just really with epsilon and two
epsilon and columns to form the basis of
the original M and we just recurse on
the remaining part so I want to get to
the next result so there are other ways
you can perform this reduction you can
fine-tune the parameters but the basic
idea is that why do we lose this Login
factor in sparsity because you know in
order to cover the entire matrix it
shrinks by a constant factor each time
so you need to pay like log log in
iterations in each iteration we find a
sparse subspace that covers another
constant fraction of the remain grows
and the sparsity increases by T right
there because we add up those those
matrices so this is why we we absorb
another login factor this is where the
factor is lost you can perform this in a
different way and get and you cannot you
can afford to not lose this login factor
in the succinct space regime so I'm not
going to get into that there are other
ways you can do it
and the important the important point is
that the space parameters we set the
recursion parameters kind of a geometric
way so that the space that we use in the
entire cover will never exceed this
serious so you will actually get a
contradiction you will get a too good to
be true covering of the so that's all
I'm gonna say about that result so this
is kind of the main framework do you
have like seven minutes
so okay so we have this result about
rectangular matrices and this already we
showed kind of already would imply if
you prove like a log log 2 plus epsilon
lower bound even against very small in
your space you already improved the
state-of-the-art rigidity for angular
matrices but one kind of annoying
downside is of this recursive argument
is that it produces a very skewed matrix
right because we only recurse on the
column space you don't know how to
recurse on the row space we never we
never reduced the number of rows in the
matrix so we end up with kind of you
know just to simplify the parameters the
matrix that this recursive argue
algorithm produces if assuming we
stopped in the last iteration which we
kind of the worst case is a very skewed
matrix the the number of rows M remains
what it was so it's like and prime can
be kind of very small it's related to
kind of T the lower bound the lower
bound parameter that we began with so
maybe poly log n or something so the
bottom line is that it produces a very
skewed matrix which is but the rigidity
parameters are actually quite good so in
order to decrease the rank below let's
say n over 2 you need to modify let's
say a constant fraction you need to
modify like almost all the entries or
let's say n over 10 entries in some row
of this major right so suppose you want
to get X square matrix from this there's
one kind of almost trivial idea that
will preserve there sparsity parameter
and we'll make this matrix to a square
what is it well you can just just and
identical copies just M over n Prime
identical copies of this matrix side by
side this will be an M by M matrix of
course the rank remains the same right
we just added identical copies
but the hope is that actually the
sparsity parameter there are a number of
entries you need to change will actually
be linear in M so it will still be
you'll need to almost modify all of the
entries to decrease the rank below and
Prime the explanation is simple right I
mean if you want to decrease the overall
rank below and prime over two then you
need to decrease the rank of each block
over two right there's no other way and
the rigidity of the original matrix and
prime tells you that you need to modify
the you know almost all the entries in
some row here right just one problem
that that is that is a problem right but
that we're not gonna solve so you will
prove a rigid a lower bound for a weaker
rank regime relative to him but there's
a more problematic issue with this
argument the problem is that these rows
that you need to modify may not be the
same row so it could be a different row
in each block right and this is a direct
consequence of working with worst-case
rigidity so does it make sense so we
know that this argument tells that you
know any low dimensional subspace has to
be T far from some row but it could be
different rows in each each block we
don't know how to control that if we had
the stronger property that let's say you
fix the South space of dimension n prime
or go to right let's do the substance of
the columns right yeah it's not in the
first block there is some row that we to
change I don't see how is the same
matrix I know but this subspace is it it
when you project it on the right it's in
and it was the columns of the rows you
don't know so that's the point the
subspaces okay subspace of the of the
row so it could be a different subs it's
some specimen doesn't if it's all the
columns right the square matrix yes I so
so I think this argument doesn't work
let's I mean this is the obvious thing
to remove the people different ways of
different roles you choose to spot
person number two then that's it let's
say that in the first metric said it
should be fixed out of space that's in
the first matrix the first row is far so
this the first to avoid the second
system before if it's not the same
something that's not the thing but it's
a space difference think whatever you
want for every subspace that is the
world it's far good to fix a subspace
but the finishing the visible okay I
think what I meant if you fix the
substrates project the substrates on the
first and prime cornice that nobody
guarantees that you're guarantees on on
the original matrix it's only against
subspaces which are in this dimension
think of this especially the sort of
third of the row space this is the
column space all right then you don't
have the guarantees of zip service okay
okay let's discuss this offline all I'm
saying is that one thing is for sure if
you had global rigidity if you know that
you need to change ten percent of the
rows in each block or you have to change
Omega M times n prime please then this
trick would work fine right because it
doesn't matter just says that you need
to change a lot of entries in each block
right so so what we would really like to
do is to perform our recursive algorithm
with global rigidity unfortunately all
this nice characterization we don't know
how to perform it with global rigidity
we only know how to do it with
worst-case rigidity and they see this
kind of annoys us for a long time and
the nice nice thing we managed to prove
is actually we can we can just show a
completely black box reduction from
worst case to average case
which have uses similar ideas to the
proof that you know circuit lower bounds
against e imply that speed so it's gonna
use locally correctable code so what is
it for the non-experts what is an LDC so
an LDC is just an error correcting code
with the extra feature that every
coordinate in the original space in the
original message can be retrieved with
high probability by reading only a queue
entries Q coordinates in the the
codeword right so what we show is the
following so let's parse this we show
that the following that if you have a
matrix a which is a very skewed matrix
possibly that is worst case region right
then if you apply an ECC a q query
linear linear as ECC to each of the
columns right so you can think of the
columns as being the original messages
that you want to encode if you apply an
LDC to each one of the columns then I
claim that yi of a has to be global in
region so actually 10% of the rows are
going to be far from every low
dimensional subspace and you lose the Q
factor here so that's that's the point
so let's so three men do have three okay
three minutes so the key fact which I
think was observed by in the paper by go
drive car off
[Music]
remember the last Travis lemon and the
Shulman is the following crucial
property of linear LD C's which is not
true for general oil leases the property
is the following it says that if your
LDC is actually linear then any row in
the original message is literally
spanned and so for any row in any 10%
fraction of the row of the coordinates
in the met in the code word that you
corrupt this row is literally spanned by
Q other rows outside this 10% this is
somehow non-trivial I was hoping to
prove it but I'm not gonna prove so
again so any row here is and for any row
and for any 10% of the of the cornice
you corrupt there's always gonna be some
key rows that span this row and now the
proof is is simple suppose this matrix
is not globally rigid so suppose that's
fewer than 10% of the rows need to
modify these many entries to write this
means just by a Markov re it this means
that the average rigidity of each call
me just divided by M is T Delta over to
Q all right by a Markov argument this
means that at most 10% of the rows here
right most 10% are very far all the rest
of the rows of a of a are close just by
by the by the contrapositive assumption
this is simple Markov argument but this
means that any row right using this key
fact this means that any row is spanned
by those remaining rows all of which are
very close RT over to Q closed so if you
have so you get the property that
literally every row of a every row is
going to be a it's a Q linear
combination of close those so you get
that it's less than T over two far
that's a contradiction to the worst case
rigidity of a because a must have some
row which is far from so that's
that's it and luckily we have
reed-muller codes which we only lose the
logarithmic factor and I kind of don't
have more time for that we have further
implications to the sick regime into
polynomial data structure log arms but I
think the main message is just that
these two seemingly very different kind
of circuit models are actually the same
pretty much in the linear model it turns
out to be the linear space regime the
sink regime we show that we don't lose
anything so you did fully exquisite so
if you improve the state of the art
succinct data structure lower bounds
then we can perform in the systems
regime we something every day we don't
lose the login factor so literally any
asymptotic improvement would give you
data structure all right and it's
actually I think there it's also sorry
it's still semi explicitly I think you
still it will still only produce NP
construction yeah so we don't because we
need to check if the we only know how to
relate these two notions of inner and
outer dimension for a sub matrix and
this sub matrix kind of have to use an
NP Oracle to query if it's rigid or not
we don't know how to get around that so
I'd be very surprised if you can
literally relate to the original inner
and outer dimension of the matrix not so
I think that's the interesting question
but I that would be great to prove that
you can literally really show that if it
has Lordaeron dimension that literally
this matrix not a sub matrix this one
itself has
but I don't know how to prove that
yes I don't know if I said that the last
theorem which a glimpse over it implies
that force in the squared case if you
beat a log cubed board on unfortunately
lose another log factor due to the LDC
but if you log cubed super-well cube
then you beat the state then you beat
rigidity for some rank parameter that
then you beat the state of-the-art
rigidity but for the square case which
is kind of what we actually care about
yeah it's probably not a complete no-go
theorem it's more of a kind of a
connection proving poly log data
structure lower bound is still kind of
will not imply anything about
let's take on me
[Applause]